hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Emily wants to play
sorry for the long delay on was that
already
I didn't yeah I didn't even get out of
the gate yet give me the time to
associate myself you her hello okay so
I'm back oh yeah my cheese I didn't know
that we were that into it just yet give
me a goddamn second to get familiarised
I need to say hi to my peeps back home
so hello peeps how you doing
so now we're at the stage where we're
fighting two of them at once and it
should be relatively easy considering I
probably just need to stay in this area
and I made the mistake of wandering
around before and I didn't goddamn find
out what I was goddamn supposed to do to
unlock the secret thee I'll do that
sneakily if I die I'm gonna look that up
because I can't find it I know I can
find it I can wander around the house
alone and then get cornered oh hi okay
so I'm gonna get a more ideal location
to be dealing with you I wonder what
would happen if I just walked right into
her I imagine that would be bad thanks
buddy in blood
that's a deal why did you need to do
that - well that wasn't fair I didn't
sign up to get double-teamed
this is a bunch of [ __ ] cost more
money if you want to do stuff like that
all right here we go
whoa I said I was gonna look it up well
I guess I'm gonna die again so everyone
just wait for us to be surprised
oh hi how's it going how you doing doing
good
good to see you will not see you because
you're not looking at me okay so there's
got to be there's supposed to be
there's supposed to be a secret but I
don't know what the secret is how am I
supposed to be able to find anything if
I can't look away
oh no oh I know thank you
oh come on as much as I love hanging out
with clowns and everybody else maybe
it's like randomizing that it's the
clown and little glue a little old girl
in this one which would make it
relatively easy and I think I'd be able
to handle it but I have a funky feeling
that Chester is gonna come frolicking
where oh god where where oh hi I didn't
notice you on the box you seem to like
to float in the places that I don't
appreciate mm-hmm never go what the
clown's name is BOGO Bonzo
I'll go with the Pogo and you're Kyoko
Oh God oh hi okay fine then you just got
bumped out of it yeah
oh hi you're still there you need to go
away you need to go away now I need to
find some tape recordings around this
house so that I can get to the bottom of
the mystery of who the frick emily is
there's a lot of things that need to be
done over here that don't appreciate
your environmentally increment of me
those words didn't make didn't make when
you run away from me when I'm the middle
I'm not making sense
which room oh god no I guess the clown
gave me a little more time I could have
wandered out of that room that's a bunch
of baloney
okay I'm gonna look up exactly well yeah
okay I got it
okay I'm good let's do this Oh for
Isengard or for something for me and all
Venna for me I'm so greedy I want to
charge for me and the only things that I
care about is I myself and my dick so
here we go thank you
that's the way I was going oh hey I mean
that's convenient because what I need to
do is this yeah and now you see we've
got a secret entrance into the basement
here hello
okay oh hi I didn't even notice there
was a person there standing originally
oh that's good oh this good oh there we
go
I heard a girl in school today she's not
allowed to go back she's been to we're
gonna keep her home okay you're gonna
keep ROM now maybe because he's crazy
and full of mental powers given to her
by demons he even bought her a puppy it
was so cute oh we thought it would help
her oh poor puppy and they didn't like
it
a hole fell through Emily's old room
into the other side of the basement
today we know Emily had something to do
with it but we don't understand what's
going on no there's another one over
there but I won't turn my back on her Oh
goddamn it
what's your [ __ ] that see what you
[ __ ] okay we're gonna be quick about
this we're scared of our own daughter I
understand in our bedroom last night
staring at us yeah we're going to start
walking her down in the basement Hey oh
good parenting move lock your daughter
in the basement that's good
a bunch of all okay since town I'm gonna
go down in the basement I'm gonna be a
better a path to a because I was a bunch
of baloney what a bunch of acid tree
what a bunch of douche nozzles miss miss
this is hard this is actually pretty
hard there Chester in the mix and I
don't even know what I'm supposed to be
doing probably not going down in the
basement where I'm down deep dark
corridors that don't have an engine
probably the first mistake I made thank
you
we need Oh Nicks
he's already open thank you God wasting
time look here we go down down down down
down hello you want to give me a big hug
yeah you better slunk off into this
there's a box of three very strange
dolls down in the basement huh Emily
talks to them as if they can hear her
maybe it's a good sign it's the first
positive thing in a long time Oh God
good I went down on the bass Emily hmm
she was laying on the floor lifeless she
wasn't breathing pulse she didn't have
any huh how can you explain the fact
that you locked your daughter in the
basement then she died oh gosh
it's bad isn't it she's gonna be buying
me a little
kyoko Keiko Kito
yeah we're the dolls keep appearing
around the house I don't know if this is
just me imagining it
Arthas is really happening either way we
have to leave this place no king that's
why you're moving out after your
daughter dead nothing bad about that
nothing suspicious about it
circumstances oh god stop here back up
here oh hey Jim here back up here Hey
now I'm gonna win this you're gonna see
I'm the witness and you're gonna be gone
right now hey there
I'm guessing if you don't stare at her
she never goes away at least for a long
period of time because if she does she
wouldn't be here obviously
thank you finally what did he get me
through a door I wasn't even in the
kitchen by the time I heard the
beginning of that what a bunch of acid
tree this is douchey god damn and I'm
never gonna beat this game at this rate
I gotta beat it I got a bingo bong it oh
hi
how's it go in there how you doing mmm
uh-huh cool hmm you know you could have
done something there you seem to be a
little mobile while you were standing a
few feet from a grundle so maybe you
could have reached out a little bit
while not I mean not in that regard but
I mean you could have killed me you had
the entire potential to do that
I mean Chesire at least gives me a chase
and Keiko just moves when my back's
turned you you're pathetic you have no
excuse you want us for what I didn't
make it
oh god yeah hello where where where
there you are okay I got my eye on you
and I got my eye on escape route it
better not close on my face because I'm
gonna run away very quickly if something
bad happens namely if a Chester appears
boom
okay there you go
a scared her away whose it's a delayed
reaction to the fear that always works
that always worked I was like a few like
seconds away from being there with the
poop there's a bunch of baloney and I
hate it there's a bunch of acid tree I
was doing fine why did that not work why
did it come barreling around the corner
I guess I didn't need to stare it or I
could have ran away a little more but I
expected them to go away after I turned
the goddamn corner what about you huh
let's go you okay I did it okay
that was night does 3:00 a.m. now I've
got four or five and six a.m. unless it
just goes to six so that's probably all
for this episode thank you everybody so
much for watching I'm gonna finish this
up
what oh no oh no no thank you again
everybody as always as a person